hallo ihr lieben ich zeige euch heute
ein grundrezept und zwar das für meinen
super und saftigen schokoladen boden der
eignet sich für motiv torten aber auch
für ganz normale torten mit sahne
befüllt mit cremes was auch immer ihr
möchtet das rezept habe ich mich mit dem
jahren perfektioniert und ich finde dass
ich hier immer wieder darauf
zurückgreifen könnt falls immer
irgendwie lust hab auch irgendetwas
schokoladige jetzt zeige ich euch zu
aller erst mal die zutaten
wir benötigen ja ja die habe ich hier in
eiweiß und eigelb getrennt außerdem
weiche butter mehl baccouche weise
stärke hier habe ich noch eine prise
salz und backpulver außerdem lauwarme
milch und zucker
ich starte jetzt mit meiner
küchenmaschine ihr könnt aber auch gerne
eure handrührgerät verwenden dass es gar
kein problem und wir stellen zuallererst
eine baiser masse her indem wir das
eiweiß zusammen mit der prise salz
einmal in unsere schüssel geben und dann
30 bis 45 sekunden lang aufschlagen
[Musik]
so 30 sekunden sind um und wir haben
schon eine richtig schöne schaumige
masse erhalten jetzt gehen wir die
hälfte unseres zuckers hinzu und dann
schlagen wir das ganze zwei minuten lang
richtig schön steigt bis sich so richtig
schöne fäden ziehen und falls ein
handrührgerät verwendet dann dauert es
ein paar minuten länger
und fertig ist unsere baiser masse sagt
euch mal wie fest jeweils ihr könnt ihr
euch über einen kopf und da kommt nichts
runter so und jetzt werde ich noch
einmal ganz kurz umfüllen und dann geht
es weiter so es gibt weiter meine lieben
ich habe jetzt hier den ruhr haken
aufgesetzt für mich funktioniert das so
einfach besser ihr könnt falls android
verwendet auch weiterhin eure
schneebesen auch dazu verwenden dass es
gar kein problem
jetzt gebe ich hier die weiche butter
reihen zusammen mit dem restlichen
zucker und dann wird das ungefähr ein
bis zwei minuten richtig schön cremig
geschlagen
[Musik]
so etwa eine minute hat es gedauert auf
höchster stufe
und jetzt nehmen wir nacheinander die
eigelbe mit hinzu und immer erst
einarbeiten und das nächste so lange bis
sie komplett aufgebraucht sind
die beziehung noch am rand einmal die
butter runter dann fange ich an mit dem
eigelb
[Musik]
die eigelbe habe ich jetzt auf niedriger
stufe schön einarbeiten lassen jetzt
geht es an die trockenen zutaten und an
die lauwarme milch die milch die muss
lauwarm sein sonst würden sich küchen
bilden wenn sie zu kalt wäre und die
trockenen zutaten wie alle in eine große
schüssel und vermischt sie miteinander
damit sie später einfach habe sie ein zu
arbeiten
[Musik]
als nächstes 7 wir unsere zutaten
abwechselnd in die eier butter masse und
ich gebe immer ein paar esslöffel von
den trockenen zutaten rein dann die
milch und so weiter wenn der erste
trocken und zutaten rhein gibt und dann
die flüssigen dann würde das nicht
funktionieren dann wird sich die masse
nicht mehr schön verbinden
[Musik]
und hier nämlich auch wieder die
niedrige stufe beim verrühren damit dass
ihnen keine klümpchen gibt
[Musik]
also der letzte tropfen milch ist auch
drin
und jetzt haben wir mit ganz viel liebe
noch den eischnee runter und dafür dem
durch am besten einen teig schreiber
dann funktioniert das am besten und am
besten hilft ihr den einstieg in
mehreren schritten unter ich nehme immer
so gute drei esslöffel gibt ihn in mein
tag und dann immer so weiter
[Musik]
unser schoko teig ist fertig den
backofen habe ich übrigens schon
vorgeheizt 180 grad ober und unterhitze
jetzt gefüllt mit den teig nur noch ihr
könnt entweder eine springform nehmen
und mit backpapier auslegen den rand
nicht fetten das brauchen wir hier nicht
oder einen bug ring die backzeit
variiert kaum eigentlich da geht es
wirklich nur um sekunden oder
allerhöchstens eine minute und ich will
den heute mal in meinen bak dringen nur
noch mal einigermaßen glatt streichen
und jetzt wandert das in den ofen wie
gesagt 180 grad ober und unterhitze
circa 45 minuten die backzeit kann
natürlich variieren schaut einfach und
macht auf jeden fall die stäbchen probe
nach 45 minuten backzeit ist mein
schokoladenkuchen gar und ich habe ihn
aus dem ofen geholt abkühlen lassen und
anschließend in frischhaltefolie
eingewickelt und im kühlschrank ruhen
lassen ihr könnt ihn am besten am
nächsten tag schneiden das geht
natürlich auch im gleichen aber am
nächsten tag kann man hier einfach viel
besser durchschneiden ich finde diesen
ihnen jetzt durch zwei so dass ich drei
bühnen erhalte und mache anschließenden
richtig leckeren schokoladenkuchen
braucht wie am anfang schon erwähnt
könnt ihr aus diesem boden richtig tolle
sachen vorband auf einem motiv torte ist
weil er das supergut schnitzen könnt
oder einfach nur schöne seine füllung
rhein alles funktioniert hier
[Musik]
und ich glaube spätestens im
angeschnittenen zustand erkennt man wie
sagte kaeser schokoladenkuchen ist und
an diesem rezept gefällt mir dass wir
keine korrekturen schmelzen müssen
dieser vorgang stört mich manchmal beim
backen eines bösen aber ich finde es
geht dann auch viel einfacher und dieser
bug auf dringend richtig durch und es
ist super schokoladig ich freue mich
wenn ihr das ganze jetzt nach macht die
genauen mengenangaben stehen unten in
der infobox ihr könnt das auch ganz
einfach um rechnen falls sie eine
größere oder eine kleinere springform da
hat es auch kein problem freue mich über
eure fotos mit dem hashtag nicht die
skizzen auf instagram hinterlasst main
kanal gerne ein kostenloses abo damit
ihr nichts mehr verpasst und dann
feuchten stellen wir uns auch beim
nächsten mal wiedersehen tschüs
[Musik]